[Music]
in offensive joke news submitted by
nugget in a biscuit a coffee shop has
apologized for a gentrification joke
they wrote on the sidewalk sign
what are they arrived Hey moving into
your neighborhood making it different
[Laughter]
cream to the coffee that's actually kind
of cool yeah [ __ ] out what backs huh no
so this coffee shop is called ink coffee
it's located near five points in Denver
which is which was once a largely black
neighborhood I didn't even know there
were black people in Denver Colorado
yes really this neighborhood was largely
black once and then so now there it's
becoming one of the trendiest
neighborhoods with like breweries
restaurants apartment just like Colorado
yeah the whole state yes getting like
hella trendy and so this coffee shop
thought it was kind of funny or
something to put this sign in front of
it
happily gentler thing I believe
gentrifying the neighborhood since 2014
that's not really smart yet huh no
basically happily kicking out poor
people so rich people who come in that's
pretty much just met a lot of smart sign
there buddy yeah and so the founder of
the chain all of the chain yeah that
makes sense yeah they probably started
having those signs and like
predominately white neighborhoods and
people probably thought it was funny or
it was like humorous after the danger
occasion I was everyone else or like
they just people I let's say if they
open up in Silver Lake the
gentrification already happened and then
saw all the people there they law it's
funny you know like it became part of
the community already where everyone
knows and then so if it's a chain and
they were to establish that kind of
humor now they go into a place that it's
barely starting at gentrifying I think
you know a javo flaw anything is so
long time ago right when minorities
moved into white neighborhoods do with
something called the white flight which
is like all the neighborhoods that we
have the suburbs in la Monterey Park
whatever they were they used to be all
white suburbs but then once like all the
minorities start moving in and turning
it into like a Mexican neighborhood
Asian neighbor or whatever in walnut so
you saw it happen right oh that's wasn't
a latter half then yeah but you saw you
saw where it was probably 50/50 Asians
and then the white flight happened but
what's happening right now is the
children of all of them are coming in
and in their [ __ ] console so the
opposite is happening and then the
minorities are like why are you coming
into our neighborhoods and in their
their hat they're they're getting pushed
off and it's like a weird cycle oh yeah
yeah they're moving back in now yeah
they're moving back in from what their
grandparents and ran away from
I wish Margaret partly gentrified it
needs one I like them to me I like says
the Asian guy I know
see all those [ __ ] car thief of that
like you know the other people people
they're the past the Pacific Ocean
people sometimes like I'm not I'm not
from LA I'm from sac town yeah I'm
saying but I'd be watch I've watched
k-town slowly transform in the past like
six or seven years and it's interesting
like I have like this weird sense of
like k-town is a place I call home yeah
and I slowly see like you know just a
bunch of like white folks just walking
around like yeah I'm like oh that's
interesting I never saw that before and
then you see like the the rent getting
raised up a lot higher there's a no
parking anywhere and you see a lot of
these like
staple like Korean places that are
disappearing that's not making Cape Town
what it used to be because Silver Lake
two before it got gentrified apparently
cuz I remember that we do mission trips
there and it was like straight-up
Mexican right yeah all that [ __ ] is gone
dude and so like I think that's an issue
that I have with gentrification you take
out a culture out of a place to you know
so if k-town slowly starts to become
less and more of Korean that is it
really Cape Town like little Armenia is
not really that much like that anymore
little Filipino town or whatever you
know those places to don't even have
that cultural feel to it anymore is it
still gentrifying if white people do it
to white people because Austin Texas
it's that's happening out there too a
lot of California why people like out in
Silicon Valley or whatever the tech
industry is pretty big out there and I
know it's it's changing the local Austin
Texas community so it's like hipsters
kicking out rednecks or something
exactly like like they're you know a lot
of white people that have history in
Austin Texas like they're like our you
know we can't live in our own
neighborhoods anymore and they got to
move out to other parts of Texas and
they're like the rents getting higher
all this stuff is happening so is that
gentrification to this education as it
is yeah yeah that's crazy
thought of it that way it's it's it's
hipsters they're [ __ ] [ __ ] up they
are kind of making it better because
downtown LA was [ __ ]
I would have never lived downtown LA but
then now they're cleaning that [ __ ] up
because when there's more money coming
into the neighborhood's the police
actually come and protect it and do all
kinds of other [ __ ] it's mind blowing
like Echo Park when I was in high school
that's a place that you don't go at
night because people throw it dump
bodies you get shot there and then now
there's like white people just jogging
around and [ __ ] old like that Park what
what is that Park all by the freeway but
you know which one I'm talking about the
one with the lake
that used to be the number one area
where you could get some good ass crack
I never been there for crack but my
friends did and they told me well this
one city used to we used to do like
missionary trips to that area
specifically we would like pass out
pamphlets and [ __ ] but now let white
people are jogging there's like
Dalmatians there Shar Peis yeah you need
[ __ ] pit bulls Rottweilers now it's
French bulldogs and Dalmatians it's like
this is not a good area at all I saw
people playing frisbee dude honey can
you guys educate me why gentrification
is bad it drives out the community and
it's not kind of just erases the culture
in the community out of the come
out of the area so like people that
don't have money create like a new but
you're also raising right on people who
have lived there for a long time and
you're kicking them out of their
community so they don't have any place
to go it's like what's been happening to
Hawaii for a long time so people the
natives of Hawaii can't even live in
Hawaii because they can't pay for the
rent there so they move to like Oregon
or some other place yeah so it'd be a
different scenario where money is being
put into these like downtrodden areas
and they're fixing it up but the rent
stays relatively the same but that's not
the case
so what happens is that it'll go up
double triple like certain parts of
Oakland to like you'll even see out like
what's it called like Brooklyn Brooklyn
is mad rent different you know what this
is like this is like the type of [ __ ]
that biggie used to talk about right and
this is where a lot of like there's like
a lot of section 8 housing that was
there too a lot of government assisted
places and these people have to move out
and they're just put out I think the
balance would be if people moved in to
experience that culture but made all the
bad stuff disappear yeah like the crime
and the freaking poverty and whatever
like you know if you bring if you bring
your money but then live their way and
let people keep their like Chinatown or
whatever it is I think that would be
cool yeah you know maybe maybe if
Chinatown became gentrified but then we
could do away with all the bugs and we
could do away with you know like the bad
stuff coat it in huh it doesn't make
them money back to the investors and
stuff like you if you keep it the way it
is but you just make it nice it's just
the waste of money they probably feel
that way so that's why I asked that
question cuz I understand up to that
point but then for me I'm like then like
what's the point of like or I guess for
me would be like what's the ideal
solution then do you know what I mean
like imagine this I don't know if the
solution is but imagine like there's
like like let's say there's a group of
Abuelita grandmas that live in East LA
right like I say your grandma's still
alive and they all live there and that's
the home that they know and East LA
commerce area now it gets gentrified and
all the rent gets quite beautiful so
that entire community where they know
where they I can go to the market for
this I can do this like all that
Cyndi's they all it all disappears and
they all have nowhere to go so now a lot
of people they go to like Inland Empire
some other weird-ass place so they
almost feel like they're up rooted from
where they are where they were they've
grown up and now they're completely
thrown somewhere else that's that's I
guess quote-unquote unaffordable for
them and so they feel like they
shouldn't have to that shouldn't happen
because it's not fair
yeah yeah I get that I still understand
that a hundred percent I'm not saying
anything about that but I'm just saying
then what's the solution cuz then things
kind of tend to dwindle and then they
kind of get worse because there's no
upkeep and there's no real money
circulating to to maintain or just make
it better but just basically maintain it
so you're asking like which community
has been able to achieve a good yes yeah
I don't even know cuz that's what like I
understand why gentrification happens
cuz like that's how we were able like
our families were able to come in here
you know and like they kind of
gentrified it in their own way that's
gentrifying if it's poor people moving
in and in at least and make it their own
yeah yeah we did the same thing right
yeah I just don't know what the term is
so it's like it's like yeah I feel like
it or just doing it but yeah like it
just keeps changing and I feel like it's
kind of cyclical in a way where like it
has like it's waves of like it comes and
it goes and it just keeps changing so I
feel like it's kind of normal you know
what I mean I feel like that's kind of
what keeps things changing and it
depends on how long people have been in
that community because there are
communities here that it's like it's
been for the last hundred years Latino
you know like there's a lot of history
but then if Monterey Park right it's
been an Asian neighborhood for the last
20 years I don't know or 30 maybe it's
it's not that long
oh so then so then would this be a
solution then cuz that's a good example
that you bring up Monterey Park right so
it was predominantly white and then like
you were saying the white flight
happened but then amongst their own
people they started injecting more money
into it so it's still very predominantly
Asian but even then they had their own
so there's the white flight was and then
cuz the Taiwanese came in and ordered
Japanese and then there was the Japanese
flight in the town and a Taiwanese
flight and there's the Cantonese that
came in and the Vietnamese came into the
Cantonese and it's gentrified by
mainland Chinese now well then it's not
possible it's like gentrification has to
happen all over the place is what it
sounds like but I think that the main
difference is we're talking about like
we're talking about ethnic switches you
know that's not really what the
justification part is I think for me
like the negativity that people are
talking about gentrification is the
money part like when you gentrify a
typically red goes nut and people are
ejected forcibly right so those who
would you're talking about right now
people are leaving by choice these yeah
you it's it's been a fish like if I
owned a home in Monterey Park right and
then a mainlander offers me twice as
much money for my home then the market
price then I actually benefit and I'm
like I'm willing to leave I'm not
getting forced out of my homes yeah
because I can't afford it so so it's
happening from like one week to the next
where it's like it doesn't have to be
fast it's fast yeah yeah
it's literally like Stumptown coffee
comes in that entire plot that they come
in the next the next within the next
year it's probably double and once that
block develops the whole entire street
is like triple quadruple and then it
just affects the entire here so they
build this building that it's like
really expensive apartment starts to
become nice people pay that other
apartment copper's world they're
charging then I could charge this up up
up up up everybody gets moved up yep
yeah so it's being it's feeling forced
out of your community versus you know
benefiting from it so I think the best
example is Hawaiian natives like they
can't they don't have a job where they
can pay for the rent and pay for a
lifestyle that's normal in their own
Island they have you know yeah that's
yeah so I think that's probably how
people feel out here like there's
communities out here that's been Latino
that's been Asian for like a long long
time and then they're getting pushed out
of their own neighborhoods yeah yeah
yeah so back to this coffee house here
so the the founder of this chain said
that originally this was part of an
advertising campaign where he
saw that the campaign was a way to take
pride in being part of a dynamic
evolving community and that is inclusive
and so that that was the whole thing
like they were just it was just a bad
joke and so they did apologize for it
but before all of that though the a
window was broken at that shop and white
coffee was painted on the store so it
looked like this white people went oh
yeah that's good handwriting holy [ __ ]
yeah you're right to Doug he's like Walt
Disney I thought that was a part of the
store yeah no you had this and yeah and
then this is the window that's broken
and then there were people that showed
up to protesting because of the line
like people were furious that they were
making like I think rightfully so -
that's not it's not funny
I think the difference I here's the
difference of specifically white people
moving into minority neighborhoods and
gentrifying it it is when minorities
gentrify each other they don't do it in
a way where people have to like blend to
them but I think what Monterey park's
different what do you mean well it was
one way and then this new wave of people
came in and now it's like what the [ __ ]
like it's cultural it's like a culture
shock for the people that were already
living there
you mean like the white people the
Asians with the other the other wave of
Asians that came in like the mainlanders
in like Chinese people so I don't get
your point actually what because because
you're saying that when white people go
into minority it's not like the
minorities not have to change and adapt
to the white wait right no they do they
do have to do that's what I'm saying oh
yeah listen I'm saying the same thing
kind of happened in Monterey Park where
we're kind of having to a cuz I lived in
Monterey Park like we're kind of having
to adopt to like the new wave of mean
mainland Chinese people we don't like we
don't we don't really you know we don't
we just call exist and everyone does
their own deal we don't have to live
there you don't change our lifestyle
yeah
they changed the stores but
they don't impose their culture and
their lifestyle upon us so for example
if so for example if you live in a
minority neighborhood yeah it's very
very common for a lot of good to hang
their clothes outside right the minute
it gets gentrified people have what the
hell is that
no you need a dryer buddy okay so now
you change the entire culture yeah but
wouldn't mainland Chinese huh if they're
blowing boogers they don't care if
you're blowing boogers or not no they
let people exist the way that they've
been existing but the difference is I
think white culture is very different
from a lot of minority cultures so what
I mean by this is specifically on Maui
have family living there right and there
are white people moving in and bringing
the mainland culture there so people
have been doing what do you call it when
you bury the pig in the in a dirt the
kalua pork they've been doing backyard
barbecues and stuff like that
we're it's super smoky but then the
neighbors aren't cool with that and then
they'll complain and do that but they've
been doing that for so long and until
impose their culture upon others I see
what it happens between white people too
so like you know within LA you know you
we're not used to barbecue culture but
if you go to a small town in Texas or
whatever everyone's barbecue is smoky to
them it's nostalgic it smells good it's
great but you bring a guy from LA and
over there he might complain a lot and
be like yo your [ __ ] is smoking my stuff
so I think that's the reason why there's
so much tension because the culture is
just different yeah a lot of minorities
they kind of figure it out differently
they don't always have to have to
confront each other complain to each
other and they don't discuss things like
that yeah whereas you know in in white
culture I think everybody's always
communicating verbally about issues that
they have with each other that's true
it's like my neighbor I told you this
when he was banging on the wall and I
was so like this one wants to [ __ ]
fight you know that's right right
minorities they take it as you want a
fist fight it's very different yeah so I
think that's the reason why there's a
lot of tension is because the way they
handle problems the way to communicate
all those things are a lot different
there's no mutual understanding so they
come in
and then they they do things differently
and they're not used to accommodating to
other people's culture so then there's
like all this head button happening but
that's a good thing though because I
think that's when they learn yeah so now
this founder he says that he can be
talking to his employees and then
educating himself and his employees
about cultural sensitivity cool he said
it's a good thing because yeah because
they had but now they could talk about
it oh yeah something cool came out of
that
[Music]
[Music]